see where the imam conference we came to
amja here to get you know some answers
this is abhorrent this is appalling and
this bill was passed for five-year-olds
it's some very scary stuff
the
lgbtq concepts cross-dressing anal and
orals we've been feeling like no one's
addressing this for the last 10 years
and they're not addressing with
confidence what's ironic is that the
same people who are pushing for these
things are also pushing for things to be
organic and natural well i am i am with
the with the opinion of
100
i think this was pretty expected
absolutely we need to be the ones that
uh establish the foundation for our
children i remember as a kid we didn't
even like think about something as wi-fi
access the amount of pressure that's
being put
on the muslim community and on the
entire world is disgusting do you feel
like exercising our free speech
exercising our freedom of religion
within the law of the land that this is
a great place for christians and other
unconscious people to work together
[Music]
and i want every single one of you to
support eddie from the dean show
financially and otherwise but in what
way
i want you to support his new project
the dean center it's going to be a
transformative experience this center
why because it's going to be a masjid
it's going to be a place of worship it's
also going to have fitness facilities
and it's also going to be a taoist
center to call people back to allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala muslims and
non-muslims and we trust eddie
completely i for one will take a
thousand bullets for eddie he has a
vision he has more than 15 years of
experience in the tower he's had a huge
success with the dean show and he has
the support of many dua and preachers
and scholars from all around the world
it's going to be an amazing project for
everybody go to the deancenter.org
donate now
[Music]
so here's what i'm asking you you have a
hard time hearing this from me but this
is for for 10 years old and up and this
bill was passed for five-year-olds so
i'm liking brothers and sisters we're at
the mj convention we're going to be
talking to different imams to get their
reaction to this
latest news that just came out where
chicago public schools will be teaching
governor pritzker's new controversial
sex education
curriculum which aims to provide
more explicit instruction to illinois
k-12 students on the
lgbtq concepts cross-dressing anal and
oral sex and abortion at early ages i'm
going to continue on because this is
what they're going to be reading and
then
commenting on
the article continues and says sex
education will begin at kindergarten
according to the new curriculum with
lessons on gender identity third graders
will learn about how they can take
hormone blockers to change to change
from boy to girl or vice versa in sixth
grade students will be instructed
on anal
and oral sex
condom wearing and pregnancy
option of abortion so this is what's
going to be taught to children
in the schools
and we want to get the muslim imam's
reaction to this let's go meet them and
get their reaction i want sheikh this is
uh no stranger to the show sheik willie
basuni how are you doing shay pretty
good alhamdulillah thank you you look
great eddie you too
so i want you to this is a news article
this just came out so this is what's
going to be implemented in the chicago
schools and and we we need to come to
our scholars to learn how to address
these things please read this question
and we'll get an answer from you so you
read the news report
what do you have to say
that
you know communities need to work harder
the massages need to work harder
especially starting from the parents we
need to train the parents tell them the
reality of what is actually going on
it all starts from iman it starts from
taqwa it starts from teaching your kids
your family starting from yourself
that these are
realities that we are facing and the
least that we can do is you know turn to
allah
and really start on ourselves and really
be aware of the realities like who knows
what the next decade holds
may allah protect us keep us safe i mean
unfortunately the article about
pritzker's curriculum and the changes
that they're talking about having at
every level
of the public educational system
sadly it's not surprising but is no less
shocking
due to its inevitability
the teaching of these sorts of concepts
of the
gender choice and other sorts of things
from ages as young as five years old
we're talking about a block of
individuals that represent maybe five
percent of the entire
population of the united states likely
far less even than that and for them to
have that much sway and that much
control over what is being taught
especially about something that is so
life-altering as this sort of topic of
gender identity sexual behaviors and
even changing of sexual identities
sex change operations as options for
choices as young as
sixth grade
this is abhorrent this is appalling
this is the state and
vested interest taking
control of children's lives
and actually
i heard a comment from somebody recently
saying about a comedian commenting about
how these are individuals that have
chosen a lifestyle whereby they are not
going to have children and they have
chosen to make themselves the arbiters
of what parents who chose to have
children get to do with their children
or in this case actually can't do with
their children as far as educating them
according to their morals their values
their beliefs and their structures they
are overriding parents who had children
by choice even though they chose a
lifestyle that prohibits and procl has a
proclivity against having children
it's unimaginable
life first and foremost i say
alhamdulillah for islamic schools you
know
especially
the importance of giving our
children the ability to go to an
environment insha'allah where they can
be safe from this type of knowledge and
this type of information and being
exposed to all of these matters
really the communities need to take it
very seriously to establish the islamic
schools
not only just to establish established
schools but to focus on building good
curriculum so that they're not worried
and concerned about
if not sending their kids to a public
school system or
private schools that we have something
great to offer for them instead
inshaallah because subhanallah these
situations are only going to continue
and get worse so we need to be proactive
to create that environment insha'allah
for our children at the masajid and the
is
[Music]
you know so how
should parents now who are you know in
this situation of potentially having to
send their kids to public school being
affected by this what's your reaction
when you hear something
you know
there is a rule in general which is in
pr they say identify yourself before
somebody else identify you
and outside that concept in islam it's
so important to do an education
and
creating a muslim who's resilient
creating a muslim who understand the
religion
occupy the
give them hell knowledge
things that make sense to them
and make sure that they understand that
so when they go they
are resilient they have that defense
mechanism
and i say as much as we read today about
these issues it became more important to
me to talk about the importance of
talking to our children about these
issues in earlier age than what we used
to do before that's number one number
two i think it's important for us to be
involved
and to make sure that we protect our
rights as a citizen of this country
from allowing some people to enforce
their agenda on us
public it's a public square it should
not be a square a place where people
with certain agenda to force us into
their agendas so
that will happen unfortunately
by you know being engaged
having that push back uh being involved
it's not going to happen by
going away putting yourself in a shell
you know and and that's a battle that we
have to pick and i think we can
win it with common sense with science
with
faith communities coming together
and holding your ground be very clear
about these issues no wish washy about
it
and that's that's in my opinion the way
to go so the first step i would say
started at home
there is a great responsibility upon the
parents right now to take on that
responsibility of teaching their kids
what's right and what's wrong and
implanting that in their hearts from an
early age so school is the first place
where they learn school is the first
place that they practice there was
actually a study done in
back in in the 80s
of people who are doing uh masturbation
okay as as being
you know a problem in the community and
so on and so forth and they said they
found that the kids between age two and
three years old are exposed to some
scene of sexual scene uh here and there
and this is where it builds up in their
life so imagine if they're being taught
that in school in public school openly
like religion is not allowed in schools
and they don't do it in public school
why are they trying to force the sex ed
why are not giving choice to people who
wants to learn it to do it and people
who don't want to learn it not to do it
like they isn't that the freedom that
they're calling to so i think we we
should we should fight it back we should
you know
with with all the respect to follow the
law and follow the law of the land that
we live in but it doesn't mean we could
just surrender to the the harm that is
coming to our children they go to public
school they benefit from public school
and there is nothing that they could do
so i think the parents have a great
responsibility to stand together muslims
and non-muslim and you'll find people
even non-muslims who are against this in
schools so we should all stand together
for this cause to minimize that harm and
bring in benefit inshallah because you
have obviously within the laws of the
land with within the parameters you have
free speech so you shouldn't be you
shouldn't fear i mean speaking you know
freedom of religion yeah and and that's
something i should not be
forced you should not impose on my kids
and my
self or my family whatever other
people's belief is this should be kept
you know free public free square for
people to practice the religion freely i
mean you send your kids to learn math
science rights uh and all the other
sciences but then you know you come to
to the school and they got you know
they're teaching kids these uh you saw
in the article you know about what it's
it's kind of you feel embarrassed
discussing it you know oral sex you know
and uh
the uh
hormone blockers you know you can take
your time and you know until you
identify yourself kids at such a young
age it's just you know it's mind-blowing
it is but again like
unfortunately living in a time where
sexuality is
expo kids exposed to sexuality in a very
early age way more than before you know
i don't mind to talk to my kids about
sexuality but i talk them in the frame
that they can understand you know i
don't want people to
see themselves through this sexuality
identify themselves through sexuality
that's not how you identify that's if
you are empty you fight i identify
myself as a
a servant of allah you know i don't
invite even as a male of him
and what allah and also using a common
sense you know
um so
that's what i would say i think we need
a lot of people and i would i call upon
every muslim
every person of faith every person of
common sense and psychology and biology
and sociology to speak up
speak up the truth don't be looking for
the funds don't be worried about your
you know money or funded or job speak
the truth because we are at a curving
point in our society today and it is our
obligation as muslim to contribute to
protect morality in the united states of
america so making brothers sisters you
know we're at with the mja another imam
getting his reaction you guys seen what
we're talking about the article there
you just read it what do you have to say
no it's uh
it's abhorring and if if you
as a muslim
as a person of integrity as a person
with any moral christian jew god
conscious people yeah yeah
this isn't an issue of like um liberal
versus conservative this is an issue of
you know keeping things as
you know natural
what's ironic is that the same people
who are pushing for these things are
also pushing for things to be organic
and natural yet you're going against the
very thing that nature
supposedly pushed in
um and created right obviously we
believe in a creator
um
but it's uh it's something that um
it
should be terrifying and it is meant to
terrify but we should be
very wise in how we react and this is
why muslim organizations are needed
um we have to have a plan we have to
know how to actually
part of us living in the west um
living in the united states is that we
have to
really
fortify ourselves and our families and
make sure that we're protecting them and
not only protecting them but actually
making sure that we are a force of good
out there it's not enough that we just
put ourselves in a bubble or become
insular but then we actually go out
there and be like hey guys there's an
alternative to all of this what you guys
are doing there's something better can i
show it to you it's islam
right and this is something that's very
good and it has a solution for a lot of
the problems that you face and it has
answers for a lot of questions that you
have and it has instead of you
questioning your identity and
questioning you know what i mean the
body that god gave you maybe question
the ideas that you've been sold your
whole life and see that there's
something better out there you know what
i mean because if you know that it's in
the mind then inshaallah ta'ala we can
work on that if you know that it's in
the heart if you know that it's in the
spirit we have answers for all of that
there's there's a better medication
it's very interesting because we know
that the only one who doesn't have a
gender is the creator of the heavens and
earth so it's a slippery slope if
muslims you know fall into i like what
you said you have to be firm on your
identity know who you are you know
there's the male there's a female but
now this whole gender fluidity where you
know it's a very dangerous place for can
you even you know for someone to
entertain this at all as a muslim you
know where where can they end up you
know because again like i said the only
one who doesn't have a gender is the
creator that heavens in the earth
so i think there's two arms the muslim
community have to use one from a
religious perspective for us as a
muslims and not only all people of faith
this issue is something very grounded
very easy to be proven the other
arm of our community it should be
science people who are
in
psychology people who are in biology
this is science you know what you will
die and you will be in your grave and
100 years later we dig your grave we all
know you are a female or male
you can't change this fact you know i
think there's a lot of confusion caused
by this kind of approach to our children
we need more studies more numbers we're
willing to challenge this on a science
base
the
people who are pushing that agenda you
know what we never
felt in any time in our life that our
religion contradicts signs
so i'm 100 sure that what islam teach us
will never contradict what signs say
so but what do i need from our muslim
psychologist people in this profession
people in biology and
other people of faith and common sense
to come and to challenge these ideas and
to push back you know i think if we
study the impact the negative impact of
these areas in our children
we will find a lot of things that
support what we
saying and promoting as people of faith
do you feel like exercising our free
speech
exercising our freedom of religion
within the law of the land that this is
a great place for christians and other
unconscious people to work together what
we believe is
right for our children is this something
that we can work together on
absolutely i've actually recently been
getting involved with the movement we
have here in dallas or not here in
dallas but in dallas
where evangelical christian
congregations are partnering with
especially muslims
to muslim leaders actually was a medium
of muslim imams
to start to form a bond and form a form
a platform where they can work together
get to know one another and stand side
by side because evangelicals are some of
the most opposed to muslims in general
but they're trying to break that cycle
within their own communities
and they recognize that although we seem
to be at odds we share so many things in
common especially these sorts of uh
conservative values especially when it
comes to family and society and things
like that etc so we share a lot in
common and when we stand
beside one another and speak out against
these sorts of things it's going to be
much more effective because they see
there's not just an isolated few in this
in a minority demographic whatever it'll
show the greater and greater
bonds of fraternity around these issues
and that this is not
what the majority wants this is not what
the people of values and people of
morality want and that we need to turn
society back from the precipice that
it's racing towards thank you so much
would you advise parents to keep their
children out of
public schools at all costs
100 percent
there are pros and cons
to
public school private school home
schooling
unschooling whatever you want to call it
there are pros and cons but there
you just look at the realities today of
public schools and what they are pushing
the agenda they're so open they're so
obvious about it
it's just a no-brainer for me personally
you could not pay me anything to put my
kids in public school i may allah
protect our families but i think it's a
no-brainer every muslim should any
decent righteous pious upright person
should really consider
that if this is what is going on in the
public schools one hundred percent
try your best you gotta
you know that money is not at the end of
the day money and those a pluses and
those report cards that's not what we're
here in this dunya for it's about
protecting yourself and your families
from a fire yeah subhanallah um
you know i remember in the 90s we had
the challenges and you know in the
communities they were talking about
building massages in summer schools i
remember as a kid we didn't even like
think about something as wi-fi access
and then now with the internet we're
exposed and our kids are exposed to
everything and as as a father
my kid being in sixth grade one of them
in seventh grade one of the things is
how that day will come well they'll be
tested with this so
we want to be on the offensive and we
want to be proactive of teaching our
kids about uh any everything about
somewhere samsung there's a bunch of
rituals or stories of the prophets
or certain things we do on naive or
certain days but rather it's a complete
way of life a system of life
that addresses every aspect of life and
that we want to give them the confidence
and empowerment to feel that sam has
answers to all that they go through in
life and especially this particular
topic whether it's relationships guy and
girls
the whole lgbt movement where they're
able to have wisdom and how to deal with
it but also understand what their
identity is uh what they stand for
it's like it reminds me the story of
when he went to the king of rustam and
he had barely any clothes to remember
him cover himself
he could have said allah said prophet
muhammad saw he said in allah allah sent
us
to take people from being slaves to
others to being slaves of allah
and one of the first things is freeing
ourselves and our kids feeling that they
don't have to follow the standards of
society so even if they learn or are
taught certain things in school we give
them the tools to be able to process and
filter certain things out whether it's
this philosophy class evolution whatever
it may be we have to prepare them for
that so then they realize that sam is a
way of life that addresses every aspect
of life so then now they realize they're
equipped not because of fear not because
of culture but rather you understand
that actually this is who i am as an
individual so no matter what they're
thrown at them they're able to go back
to the source and that doesn't mean
perfection what it means that they
realize islam is the only thing that is
perfect would you say that this is the
time you know many have
maybe been a little bit reluctant to
talk about this scared that you know
maybe
they can have a backlash but you
encourage more imams to talk about this
you know to talk about this important
topic where where would you say you know
in this area should people come out you
know and start to address these things
more because you can see laws are being
passed you know this thing is spreading
yeah i just say
take your religion from the quran and
sunnah take it from what allah said
have taught us take your religion from
the trust of the scholars
and i want to say i personally don't
like
99 percent of the older man the scholars
and imams
very clear about this i think where some
people get confused when they
see some political statements or
positions and i wanted you to understand
that these political positions or
statements it could be calculated
between advantage disadvantage it's not
meant to teach your religion or your
moral stance
but it doesn't mean that it is 100 wrong
or 100 right but again when i want my
religion i don't take it from certain
politician or a political statement that
you make or a coalition that you make
this that's not how when i when i work
for example with a
christian group or a jewish group or a
buddhist group doesn't mean i'm
supporting these ideologies or this
faith i disagree with them but for
whatever political reason i'm doing that
position but this has to be made clear
by those people who
taking these positions and those people
watching and we we should not mix the
two together being so
dangerous now
to the young ones and trying to protect
our children do you think we've heard
some scholars even say that they should
keep their children away totally from
the public institutions you know what
would you say to that well i am i am
with the with the opinion of
keeping our children away from public
school or at least if they can't after a
certain age like fifth grade sixth grade
should be over middle school this year i
went to high school here i came from
egypt to high school i know how high
school is dangerous yeah very dangerous
to
to survive it is very hard you are
surrounded by people who are doing
things that you want to do you're
surrounded by people who encourage you
to do wrong you're surrounded by a
community and it's open i went to public
school to to say it very clearly
surviving in public school is almost
impossible except if allah helps someone
to do so parents they throw their
children to public school they don't
follow up with them they don't know what
they're learning they don't know what
they've been taught uh and i want to
tell you a story on that i had a cousin
a six-year-old cousin he came once from
school and this was a problem in texas
and he said that the teacher did a trick
for them today she said close your eyes
and when you open it up jesus will give
you some candy so he said when we opened
up our eyes you know we found the candy
on the table so we love jesus since that
you see this little thing it it is a
problem with daki that they're
implanting something in their heart that
grows with them so imagine they already
know things they're exposed to the
internet they're exposed to social media
and they have all these are opening to
them now they're gonna teach to them
specifically in schools in an open
matter
manners are lacking in schools so i
would say i am with the scholars who say
at least withdraw them at the early age
like fifth if they can be in public
school we have homeschooling we have
k-12 we have other alternative that we
do the best to minimize if allah
subhanahu ta'ala you know with his qatar
and his knowledge and his wisdom decide
that they'll be guided they'll be god if
allah decide otherwise yes but we have
to do our part we have to take the means
and rely upon allah in it that's
beautiful keep them out of the public
schools i'll say two things first i
lived in chicago for seven or eight
years
so i think this was pretty expected this
is not actually a surprise to me
chicago is a big big
city it's very liberal there is there
are lots and lots of work
that has been
going on for years and years and uh the
muslim community by the way in in
the state of illinois and chicago is the
biggest in the united states we have
eight hundred thousand muslims
i thought the the i used to think there
are three four hundred thousand uh for
yeah three four hundred thousand when i
lived here but i actually hear the um
the mayor last ramadan saying muslims
are eight hundred thousand so if we are
eight hundred thousand in this city and
we don't make the difference and we do
not make an impact
i think we need to uh
really think about it seriously now now
the the
the problem is actually knocking on your
door
there is no way out of it
you cannot say yes
should we all homeschool our kids should
we sponsor more islamic schools
what is our impact in this uh and again
should we just stand
in the defensive position which should
just defend our morals
when are we going to take the initiative
take the um
make a step further and start addressing
these issues
i think this is a a very alarming thing
and and i honestly
feel uh
it's a big challenge and and
for families who have kids this age
and i honestly don't know how we're
going to be dealing with that
you feel that this is uh
this is an area that jews and christians
and other god-conscious persons can work
together in this area to try to
educate people and try to protect our
children
from this
yes actually every thursday i meet with
a lot of pastors online uh we first
start meeting and mental health
professionals so the first thing we used
to talk about is the opioid crisis and
then mental health and then suicide
and now also these are some of the
things that people go through uh porn
addiction and so forth so the christians
they also talk about the 12-step process
and the first thing i always talk about
is acknowledging and wanting to change
so i do think there is a lot we can
learn actually from their experience
because they're more open and they don't
have that stigma of perfection or like
you know actually even their past would
say i experienced one two three and this
is
my way of recovery so that give
practical solutions so i think we can
learn you know sometimes we have to move
that stigma perfection work together and
realize that we have some common goals
we're very clear about our beliefs but
there's a lot more to work on uh i think
what's your advice until this gets
figured out hopefully for the better god
willing should muslim
parents keep their kids at all costs out
of public institutions schools
i don't think there's even really a
question about it if you have any
concerns around these issues and as
muslims
we should it shouldn't be a question of
whether or not we do but if we're being
honest about
our community and the thoughts and the
ideas that are spreading around our
communities we have to word it in that
way but if you have any concerns about
these sorts of things being taught to
your children from the ages of five and
even younger if you look at some of the
books that are available for kids even
younger than that then absolutely you
need to keep them out of any system
whether it's public or private that is
going to expose them to these sorts of
things
historically in the west
families and cult and communities had
control over the education of their kids
these were the small school houses that
many of my ancestors actually went
through where it was a community and
they taught their values to their kids
they were in 100 control of the values
the religion the the etiquettes the
morals that they were teaching to their
children we've lost that when we
abdicated that right to the state and
now the state is making decisions that
very few of us would support and so if
you're concerned about that in any way
shape or form then you absolutely need
to take back control of the education of
your children last and leastly not to
not to diminish this in any way it's
your responsibility in front of a law to
deal with these things and if you don't
you will be answerable
subhanallah
the the amount of pressure that's being
put
uh on the muslim community and on the
entire world is is disgusting so this is
going to basically this is trying to
modify humanity this is trying to change
the way in which people have naturally
been programmed to understand what
relationships are and they're not it's
not good enough that they're going to
put pressure on adults now they're going
to go after children they're talking
about kindergarten in california they're
talking about transitional kindergarten
they make lgbt like clubs and groups and
virtual meetups this is a way that
they're brainwashing children to
basically indoctrinate them with an
alien idea that's going to just destroy
society so subhanallah you know may
allah protect us may allah stop this
you know horrific
propaganda they're spreading and i
really think once we get to this level
of extreme
americans are going to start waking up
and realizing you know what this is
taking things too far they're claiming
to be the victim but now they've become
the oppressor and i think muslims need
to wake up and the general american
public they need to wake up and realize
what's really going on with this
sickness absolutely we need to be the
ones that
establish the foundation for our
children
not the public school system and there's
definitely an agenda
in many different states we've read many
numerous news reports about them trying
to infiltrate the system and and add and
even you'll find this
in the books
that our children uh are being given by
the public school system as early as
kindergarten as early as first grade and
alhamdulillah that we have
for the communities that do have the
opportunity to have the private schools
and the islamic schools and if there
isn't that opportunity we really need to
focus on ways to
assist the families that may not have
private schools or islamic schools close
by so that we can train them and teach
them to give them homeschooling
opportunities
to prevent
these uh to being exposed to such
terrible things subhanallah from such a
young age and me personally i have two
daughters alhamdulillah right now in
islamic school
and that summing school only goes up to
eighth grade in the area that we're in
and i know for sure i spoke to my wife i
said if we can't inshallah expand our
school to high school i'm going to have
to drive them to chicago every morning
even if it takes an hour hour and a half
to get there and come back there's no
way i can
put them in an environment that's like
this subhanallah for you to say that
you're not a male or female because god
almighty is the only one who doesn't
have a gender he's not like anything
that you can mad them a father imagine
and now you're trying to make yourself
into a god aren't you by saying i'm not
a male or i'm not a female you know
you're taking this approach and if as a
muslim you know if you're not well
grounded in your deen you can go down
this slippery slope and fall into this
yeah 100
see the issue is
if
i follow whatever i feel like that's not
a solid ground to stand on because your
feelings change every day and you can
change and literally there's there's
people like that of course that we know
um we have to
ground ourselves in something much more
stable we have to ground ourselves in
something way more solid and obviously
that's you know our faith in god god
himself because there's no firmer ground
than belief in god right so
if i'm just leaving it up to my whims
and my desires those could literally
change and a lot of times we think that
it's actually coming from ourselves but
we're so influenced and indentured in
the culture and the media and the things
that we consume that we don't realize
that they're influencing us on a daily
basis so you're getting influenced and
instead what we're saying is maybe we
should you should be doing the
influencing maybe there's a better
influence something pure or something
pristine from god so couple more
questions do you feel more imams now
should take a more proactive approach to
educate their communities and to talk
more about this
so
yes
imams definitely have to be proactive
and many of them are
imams have a a job right that we
things like this are going to keep on
popping up and today it's this
tomorrow's going to be something else
just like if you told me this would
happen five years ago i'd be like that's
nuts that's crazy and five years from
now may allah protect us it's going to
be something even worse than this right
so i think the jobs of the imams is to
really think long term and to figure out
how can we
really educate our communities to
weather these storms so instead of
dealing with one fish at a time we're
gonna teach them how to fish our
community really how to
weather like i said these storms that
are coming at us instead of being like
one storm at a time sorry once amount of
time but
how do we protect ourselves how do we
have that solid basis that solid
foundation that our faith should give us
right and that's i think the bigger goal
of a lot of the imams because otherwise
you're playing guacamole with a lot of
these issues it's just going to be one
afternoon you're not going to know how
to deal with it if you're just dealing
with the surface issue what's what's
actually going on right there's
something bigger going on i'm not saying
that there's a conspiracy or anything
i'm just saying this is the way that the
dunya works this is the way that this
life works and we have to as muslims
have that solid grounding that
foundation our belief our faith and and
be able to do that inshallah you're one
of the few imams that are out there on
the podium talking about this do you
feel a lot of imams should come out of
their shell and address this now what
are you seeing now is this the time
because a lot uh hold back maybe feeling
like they're going to be cancelled they
might suffer some
legal repercussions within the law
within freedom of speech what can imams
now who see where the imam conference we
came to anja here to get you know some
answers talk to us yeah i mean yeah
definitely imams need to come out of the
shell you know some of them can speak
more eloquently they can speak with more
wisdom we need to speak with wisdom but
we need to speak with conviction we need
to speak with confidence i just gave a
khutba on this topic yesterday at one of
the islamic center of wheaton one of the
large masjids here and just a number of
people that came up to me both both old
and young they did they said like we've
been we've been feeling like no one's
addressing this for the last 10 years
and and they're not addressing with
confidence and what they really
appreciate is that just we have to speak
with confidence and i think it's
building a level of frustration
especially when it comes to muslim
children parents don't even know what to
say and if muslim leaders are going to
remain quiet and they're going to shy
away from the issue
then you know who's going to guide them
who's going to speak so i think they're
afraid to alienate people but you know
what we have legal protections it is a
free country and freedom goes both ways
somebody wants to be free to practice
whatever you know uh
immoral lifestyle that they want that's
fine i should be free and i am free to
be able to express my opinions and my
detest uh and my dislike and and and my
views of i think this is absolutely
immoral behavior there's nothing wrong
with that and we actually protected by
the first amendment so we should not be
scared we should actually just speak up
speak the truth speak it in a wise way
speak it in a respectable way but in a
way that's actually going to guide our
community so yeah it is time for more
people i'm tired of being the only one
who's really talking about this issue
and so i can help guide other people on
how to convey that message we got to do
it man last question should muslim
parents
at all costs keep their kids out of
public school
so i mean you know some can some can do
it some can't do it you know the ones
who can afford it and the ones who can
do it yes i mean homeschooling is an
option in most states in this country
it's enough it's a fantastic option uh
private schools are an option uh if for
people who can afford it this is what
christians are doing this is what
orthodox jews are doing this is what you
know so many other people who don't
agree with this uh this this uh sexual
gender ideology that's being shoved down
our thoughts are doing so yeah muslims
need to realize that if you protect
yourself it's not about living in a
bubble it's about protecting your
children you can educate them about
what's going on in the world but we
should be the ones to teach them these
things and we should teach them at a
time in a at an age when it's
appropriate for them to understand that
yeah one last thing came to mind is this
a good place where christians jews other
other communities can work together with
muslims
on this matter and this is exactly the
place where we can't agree on everything
else there's some issues we're going to
not agree on politically but this is the
opportunity where
orthodox uh you know conservative
christians conservative jews orthodox
jews sorry conservative jews are kind of
on the liberal side they're coming out
and they're approaching they're like hey
let's team up on this issue because we
we uh
this is a minority that acts like a
majority lgbt lobby we need to stand up
together and face them together because
it's it's in all of our best interests
so yes we absolutely need to team up
together and i'm hoping to team up with
anyone it doesn't matter whether we
agree on some other political issue or
not we need to work together on
something that at least we agree you see
eye to eye on it and it's going to
affect our society it's going to affect
our kids it's going to affect the fabric
of america keep your kids out of uh
public school i i
i tell everybody i'm a t so as an imam
we're already busy but i make it a point
to actually teach at our local islamic
school so i'm an islamic studies teacher
as well for the high school students and
there's not a topic that's off the table
we put it all there i don't believe in
keeping the kids in a bubble or blind my
students know everything it's not that
they're
and it's not that we're exposing them
too much but we're trying to make it so
that they are proactive see i'm teaching
my students not defense i'm teaching
them offense so we actually teach them
how to give da'wah how to actually do
good in the world not just like oh i'm
going to send my kid off to college and
i'm going to put a hopefully that bubble
that i put him into when he was in
islamic school he's going to stay in
that bubble no i actually make sure that
when they go out in the world they're
talking alhamdulillah many of my own
students who have graduated i've been
teaching for like six seven years now
many of them are presidents of msas or
setting up dawah tables or engaging
they're talking they're doing a lot of
things they're very they've been very
i'm very proud of them some of them have
actually established prison dawa
programs my students i'm like wow you
guys are
but the point is we need to put them on
the offense because the best defense is
actually a good offense and if we just
say no i'll just teach you enough quran
so that you can be protected quran is
great it will protect you yes
but the quran was meant to be spread as
a light to mankind and if we just keep
that light to ourselves
we're doing ourselves in the quran a
discredit last question christians and
jews and muslims this is an area we can
work together in oh 100 and we should
um and not only this but we can actually
help the christians in our jews i think
anymore because islam offers better
answers
see the reason why a lot of christians
and jews might not be doing as well on
this front or they're trying to and they
don't have the tools and i think islam
actually gives us so many better tools
because it's on a more solid foundation
and this is why for muslims for the most
part alhamdulillah haven't been
susceptible to this for the most part
because of that solid foundation that
the quran gives us so yes we can
definitely have
cooperation we need to but
as muslims we have something very
valuable and we need to stick to it and
help help spread that light in the world
inshallah
is this something that jews and
christians and other god-conscious
people people who claim to be
god-conscious that they can go ahead and
work together in this
protecting the children i hope so but
you know let's be honest you know i
think
muslims are
the uh i would say the biggest fifth
group that is standing in front of these
uh uh um
movements
yes you could find some catholic
churches somewhere we could find some
jewish community somewhere could find
but that actually is not the official or
let's say not the mainstream
stance of these faith groups
unfortunately
like you know when you work and and
with the with the faith leaders in a big
city like chicago you could easily tell
that
everybody now right now is
moving too fast towards supporting all
the causes that the community is
supporting faith you know faith faith
group leaders
just don't want to be alienated
and unfortunately
it seemed that muslims are going to
go through this
alone
thank you very much
you were talking about you know um this
when these thoughts come to the human
being right to the muslim it's it's not
that they should be left to simmer and
grow they it can end up being haram
where you need to get this out of your
mind as quick as possible you know
because people go off saying that you're
not going to be accountable for your
thoughts and then you actually address
this issue that this is something that
you don't can you elaborate you know
what i'm talking about yeah yeah
you know sometimes i hear this statement
it's okay to have these desires as long
as you don't act upon them i think that
actually opened the door to promote
to make people more closer to go into
that direction i think that statement is
not good it's not right
i think
one of the things that islam teach us is
the importance of the action of the
heart your heart is more the most
important part of your body
and you have to keep it pure for me to
tell me oh it's okay to have this desire
to poison my heart no it's not if you
have this desire you should fight it
this is haram
can you imagine somebody like have a
desire to do something so evil
no that's wrong you should say
for allah
may allah protect and i start working on
purifying my heart that's more important
than the action
you know and then
said uh heart is the king of the body
if you corrupt the king the whole
kingdom will be corrupted same thing so
what he said about the illinois was
correct and that's why i do believe that
this shaha
these desires are forbidden desires and
you're not allowed to let it settle or
sit or sink
you actually don't act upon it it's
haram and you have to say you have to
push on it the scholars talk about
thoughts
just
give an idea for a second in your heart
those who don't
push back these thoughts it will take
them to their distractions
even the thoughts but allah will not
make you sinful by thought
but a desire no this is a desire this
means something i it's like as we say
the love of allah is a reward that you
get and
the love for haram and the desiring of
haram is a sin actually in the heart
thank you for spending some time with us
and answering those questions
we've been told that uh they're out to
kill us all salaam brothers and sisters
we went to the streets to ask americans
about islam
here's what they said do you know
anything about islam
no do you know anything about islam
no sadly do you know anything about
islam
not really do you know anything about
islam
no i'm sorry you know what islam means
islam uh
no we've been told that they're out to
kill us all
that's what you've been told
that muslims are out to kill you all
well that's what i say on tv
anything
i know it's in the middle east isn't it
well that you're going to have four
wives
brothers and sisters as you can see
there are so many americans who don't
know about islam we need your help to
change that help us to build the dean
center the first mega dawah center in
america we have 500 000 left and we need
your help to finish click to donate
right now may god almighty allah reward
all of
you cannot leave without giving you a
gift if you're not yet muslim and you're
tuning in to see what these muslims are
talking about and you'd like a free copy
of the quran go and visit the
deenshow.com
we'll take care of the postage and
everything and get it delivered to you
and if you still have some questions
about islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you assalamu
alaikum and if you like this episode of
the dean show
like this video
share this video
far and wide and support us on our
patreon page so we can continue this
work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum